hey guys my name is Jess it's the day
and the weekend is so close you can
taste it I don't know what do we can
taste like but I assume it's sour cream
and onion Pringles if you disagree let
me know in that comment box be sure to
hit that subscribe button so you don't
miss our top-five show tomorrow but for
now here's what's going on notoriously
violent and brutal racing game Mario
Kart 8 has patched out a controversial
route hand gesture in the latest update
you may or may not recognize this one
but it's called the Italian select and
is considered somewhat offensive in
places like France Spain Italy and
Portugal to avoid cementing Mario Kart
8's name in the same infamous gaming
halls as manhunt and outlast 2 Nintendo
have gone ahead and replaced the gesture
with a simple fist pump we're not sure
how it made it past our senses in
Australia in the first place inkling
girl sure still looks like she's telling
you to suck it though the update also
delivered small changes including
changing starting positions in online
races extending the invincibility period
after a spin out in online races and
Driver Me's now show proper facial
expressions for the full patch notes
head to our story on GameSpot in these
that makes me pretty sure I'm psychic
because I had a dream about life is
strange last night a new life is strange
game is in the works
please leave your psychic queries in
that comment box and I'll get to them as
soon as possible
developer don't not confirm they're
working on a follow-up to the mystical
time rewind II original and they also
drop the knowledge that over three
million people purchased the first game
much like our Far Cry 5 announcement
from earlier this week the developer
have declined to offer up any more
details on either the title or the
format of the next game don't not added
that we won't be seeing the title at e3
but they are hard at work ensuring
they're making the best game possible
finally Bungie held a live stream to
show off destiny to gameplay but what we
got was way more than just a gameplay
reveal Bungie announced that destinies
weapons have been completely revamped
the primary secondary and heavy weapons
lots of destiny have been replaced with
kinetic energy and power new weapons
were also showcased including a grenade
launcher and
gun there are also new supers for you to
enjoy warlocks are getting dawn blade a
fiery sword that lights your guardian on
fire that allows you to fire slam
enemies from above and hit them with
your fiery sword I mentioned fire Titans
are getting sentinel a Captain America s
void shield that can block damage and be
thrown into enemies and hunters can
summon an electrically charged stuff and
swing it around dangerously by way of
the arc Strider super but where will you
be able to use all of these new toys on
the four new locations which include
Titan IO nurses and Earth's European
dead zone buns you've also said there's
much more to do on the planet like NPCs
offering side quest s adventures and
more frequent public events you'll also
be able to start activities from the
planet surface and warp from planet to
planet without having to return to orbit
on the multiplayer side deciliters
crucible is capped at four before and
several modes from destiny either won't
be appearing in destiny 2 or will have
different play accounts destiny 2 is out
on September 8th for Xbox one and ps4
with PC to follow sometime later the PC
version will support 4k and uncapped
frame rates and will be available
exclusively through the blizzard app
which was previously battlenet for more
info on any of the above or to check out
the full livestream on over to game slow
that is everything I've got PJ do let me
know what you cared about stop buying
games but all our games spot now app for
all the latest an easy bits and pieces
and I will see you again tomorrow for
our top 5 stories of the whole week
[Music]